[Music]
all right this is got to be the most
tragic saddest story I've ever come
across
yes let's make it funny story all the
[ __ ] I've ever come across
and it might be a little might be a
little soon but this is what unfolded
for a New Jersey family
oh they install a brand new above the
ground pool in their backyard the house
they just bought within you know the
last couple months or whatever they just
installed the pool the eight-year-old of
the family decides to jump into the pool
jumps into the seventh seven foot eight
foot end of the pool she can't swim
above the ground pool that has different
eight foot above the ground pool in
reported yes it's like a circus or seen
anything that big well you have a boat
on they can [ __ ] do circus Olay on
that [ __ ]
circus saloon the [ __ ] the the
[ __ ] the oh the Bellagio show we got
you yeah they say this is this Wow seven
to eight feet capable of it if they
built it higher yeah well maybe it goes
into the ground a little bit that looks
like eight feet with what kind of the
pool is yeah in like those states or
like that New Jersey yeah Midwest to
because of like [ __ ] that can like go in
or like animals and stuff like that
that's a big funky roll Johnson can't
swim is drowning very sad oh no
then the aunt who is kind of supervising
this issue will also probably can't swim
she goes oh my god the daughter's
drowning so then the the grandpa comes
flying out the house 62 year old man
comes flying out the house jumps into a
pool to save the girl guess what it
surrounds - he can't swim
why didn't why isn't what the [ __ ] and
then the mother of the child no why did
they get a pool don't look at 2:00 in
the [ __ ] ow she doesn't she
what so I don't want to I don't want 11
is what I heard this story but it was
phrased in a different way where I
thought it was on Facebook yeah it said
this but it was posing it as a
conspiracy that I forget what their
connection was why they didn't drown in
the pool why they didn't drown no it was
like a you know a conspiracy thing that
you see floating around I saw it in
passing in it was just like it's the
same story it's gotta be it was like
these you know whole family travel
family drown alike
they had some connection to something I
think it might have been coronavirus
something like that who knows weird okay
yeah and it was like someone posting it
being like this is suspicious so you
know I mean look at the pool it supposed
to be eight feet yeah definitely you're
right that's their pool though
yeah they drowned in that cuz that she
looks ankle-deep dog why do things
nobody could swim this is the house now
it's starting to sound a little bit
fishy hold on and these are family
members coming to visit okay the funeral
for I mean just coming to visit whoever
didn't mean to all save in there all
these aren't dead these are all family
members coming to visit who's taking
these pictures no digging here let's see
if there's something let's look at this
poor right what do you think woody okay
everybody could stand in this pool and
not be drowning well unless the the deep
end is on the others but isn't the whole
point of an above above-ground pool is
it's much much cheaper because you don't
dig into the ground yes make a below
ground pool and I think and that's a
that's a trailer or whatever next to the
bigger porch this camera here yeah yeah
that's not a feet tall yeah is that it
goes in the ground so it's half in the
ground half above the ground the polis
is what we're assuming yeah now looks
like three feet if I had if we're giving
the story the benefit of the doubt then
half of it is in the ground yeah true
also if it's an above the ground pool
couldn't like the bat board no one knows
a plug or something or drain the water
out the kiss is drowning and draining
that easy
this whole time the person that was oh
my gosh is Johnny z1 that [ __ ] sweet
yeah yeah the end she could've jumped in
oh no I don't know oh that would be
funny why do they have this pretty
exactly maybe they were hoping to like
swimming lessons yeah true true but yeah
so they just installed it a lot of the
neighbors are speculating that this
might be the first time that ever even
used to pool if this whole family did
drown together it's really sad
but if you're a firefighter that comes
to the scene and everyone's just the
whole family's floating like this I
can't help but not laugh to let this a
funny
why there's six people face down this is
boring that's a lot of [ __ ] people do
six is like that there's like a comedy
bit the jokes getting old guy we tried
training it was like lemmings who do you
want for the most none of them oh the
baby the baby the kid I mean I'm more
for all of them I mean I think it really
tragic I mean I mean okay so everybody's
suppose it for one's cuter than the
other one though like I mean put
yourself in a situation some weird thing
going on here and none of them can swim
kids drowning you know you're gonna jump
in after the kiddie we can get it like a
pole and try to poke them out of pool
like you're gonna try the same to get
you don't know how to swim but you're
putting your life on the line for this
child Minh it makes you love the the
grandpa like because he knows he can't
swim he's gonna jump in there and try
and save the kid anyways and then the
mom you know like the police or even if
you're at the funeral or just anyone be
like yo what happened I may explain the
story it's gonna be the same thing that
we're talking about now why I want I
want to know more about this conspiracy
theory and
yeah you know I don't I don't normally
like pay much mind to it but I just it's
so specific I was like I know this story
because I was passing through and it was
like whatever the connection was it was
like these people you know were working
with this thing let's say it's
coronavirus right and all of a sudden
you know the entire families found they
can't swim in a pool at they own that
was that was the story I heard something
about a family and I thought it was the
same story but is a different one where
they jump into the pool I don't know if
they'd say apartment complex or a hotel
or whatever but they just moved in they
jump into the pool and then something
happens to all of them and then they
figured out that it was like an
electrical thing oh yeah they were
saying this could have been an
electrical thing like they got
electrocuted they rolled that out though
what if it was like the Sims and they
forgot to install a ladder I mean and
who was the person that decided to that
this would be a great idea a family full
of non-swimmers let's build a [ __ ]
pool maybe they moved into the house the
pool they're not gonna do being God
themselves yeah and I were saying it's
the first time jumping into the wall -
maybe it was like let's let's
we all suck at swimming so let's like
put our money where our mouth is and get
a pool and learn that's not so sensible
if you're gonna have to build a pool and
then you know I'm gonna learn but
wouldn't you want up dope pool you get
you couldn't go at the [ __ ] half
above oh there's pools that aren't just
8 feet continuous motion pools are like
shallow to deep yeah I guess again it's
like this pool continually eight feet
true our pools not just I've never seen
it boys maybe just three three to eight
maybe the kid didn't know that there was
a shallow end but if I Aaron's didn't
know either will they do wanted to say
oh yeah the kid was already in the deep
end oh they can't swim
yeah the shallow they could walk okay
yeah walk themselves all right like you
hold your breath and you walk you're
right what you could you could hold them
and walk true I don't know man I don't
know I don't think anyone thinks about
that when they're drowned yeah
catchin water like I'm gonna blow my air
out all the air that I'm desperately
trying to grab I'm gonna blow it I'll
out hit the bottom and I'm gonna walk
like I'm training in like the NFL
Hawaiian's I just I just I'm sad that
they died they didn't die they did they
die good night everyone
tragic partners they asked you if they
died and then you said no they did it
oh no no did today the people bet with
the picture our family members coming to
mourn yeah oh [ __ ] how could you guys
laugh at this story everybody sit
together like when I was just making he
says I didn't think it was enough sketch
the what's the one where is uh where
they're reading a note and then they
keep shooting each other and the dead
guy comes back to life and is shooting
that one and then they're shooting a
chain reaction
we're not biggest this sucks man what a
way to go yo for that sucked
I I don't blame them like I mean if you
don't know how to swim because I when I
was a kid I hadn't been like six I
didn't know how to swim yet and I wanted
to learn so I went into the shallow end
and I thought if I walk myself towards
the deep end I'd figure [ __ ] out you
know slowing the progress of changes big
rocks rules I just try I'm living
walking as a kid and it just gets deeper
and deeper I'm like and eventually gets
to the part where my toes can't even
like hit the ground without me going
underneath magical and I swear to you I
did not know how to get out and get out
of that situation that was six yeah and
I didn't know how to get out of it I was
panicking and I swear it I probably
looks hilarious from the outside like I
I thought I was dying I was like this is
it this is the last is the blurring but
then you float back up when you throw
your arm panicking your muscles are
so your your buoyancy is gone and you're
just kind of like sinking to the bottom
a little bit and then you luckily though
there's some older kids that were like
idiot and they pulled me my dad just
threw me mister yeah cuz I would be on
the side you know the playing on the
side and just holding that thing and
he's like I'm getting tired of this come
here and he grabbed me and you [ __ ]
Chuck me and I was like holy [ __ ] I'm
gonna die and he's like you're not gonna
die just move your arms and I'm like I'm
moving up but I can't [ __ ] breathe
and then I just kept going and it worked
and I was like oh [ __ ] my nose now it
traumatizes with swimming I can get so
mad like if we grab the side he would
hit us and like all that stuff why is
that something to be pissed at like if
I'm doing why it's like I'm trying to
have a good time hurry the [ __ ] up I'm
gonna kiss you
we didn't have a choice no I can't I
can't anyone like you know have their
parents teach them at a swim you know my
mom was like I can't swim and you know
we're like we're living at the beaches
I can't save my kids my dad is a great
swimmer so he's like I'm gonna put these
kids in swimming lessons cuz you know I
can't save them I can't jump in the pool
so we learn to swim you know by someone
teaching us how instead of just like get
out the side kid yeah my mom can't swim
yeah
I think my dad tried to teach me but I
didn't learn so that's why I think he
was pissed sometimes parents teaching
you isn't the best person to be teaching
you is I don't know I feel like oh yeah
I didn't get talked about my parents
yeah I'm like and we're both my parents
are actually good swimmers so they knew
the importance of swimming so we felt
like we better put this kid in swimming
classes cuz I don't want to waste my
time teaching him with us after yeah
they're only there for the fun part
I thought swimming was a natural thing
like walking for humans that you have to
learn if you're a baby like it's like
natural for your baby when you're older
you just panic knowing when I was a kid
I thought that we we all just had to
learn like it was one of the things just
like running learn the butterfly out of
nowhere no I mean that's why I don't
knows how to freestyle or anything it's
just that I thought humans just
naturally yeah learn to learn to survive
in this body of water
what a natural
swimming position Oh doggy doggy style
right yeah I mean cuz even though you
thought you found a natural way of
running is a wrong way you know the
minute you get a running coach like your
run away or where we were wearing their
followers
well that running is for competition
though that's like me or the mother the
most efficient way to run yeah because
you're trying to compete well I think
just running for the sake of running is
now like all humans should know how to
run like it's and it's like for a moment
you're like off balance and then your
foot catches it selves I think that's
pretty much you know any adults like
your age that does an honest one
don't so that's pretty weird to not know
my mom know like your age on my that's
my buddy duh did not I kill no I don't
think he could swim like yes sir in law
she's like a year older than me I think
I should have known it so I think if I
got a pool now like I had a house I
wouldn't make it more than like five
feet high you don't have might die
knowing that I'm just like I use the
pool to chill and relax if I want to
swim laps I can but I'm like what what's
the point of like not being with ya like
I have people come over and just like
but you don't like to dive deep and play
well when I dive I feel like eight cuz
we have any eight-foot pool and I feel
like damn I wish it was just a little
bit more shallow yeah yeah but you got
once I just chill in the pool that's the
jacuzzis for yeah but ones if you want
to hello people are there the job what
if you want to hold your breath and swim
at the bottom like you're a [ __ ]
halibut what if you want to be
completely weightless specifically a
house of paper here anything else is not
as fun - ah flounders yeah
[Music]
[Music]